on revient sur le cadre financier du
parti libéral du québec les libéraux
promettent d'investir des
infrastructures d'abolir éventuellement
la taxe santé et de mieux contrôler les
dépenses
est ce que tout ça est réaliste réponses
faisant maisonneuve
le plan des libéraux en matière de
finances publiques repose en partie sur
une accélération de l'activité
économique québécoise
c'est un cadre financier qui est
réaliste crédible et freins pour
atteindre leur objectif les libéraux
misent sur une croissance économique
d'au moins 2,1 pour cent en 2014 alors
que le dernier budget marceau prévoit
une croissance de 1 9%
vérification faite la banque
laurentienne l'institution pour laquelle
travaillait le candidat libéral carlos
leitao disait que les prévisions du
budget marceau était atteignable mais
que la marge d'erreur semblait metz et
en janvier dernier la banque
laurentienne misait plutôt sur une
croissance de 1,8 pour cent de son côté
le mouvement desjardins a récemment revu
à la baisse ses prévisions de croissance
pour l'année en cours
desjardins prévoit une progression de
1,7 pour cent du pib québécois les
libéraux pensent néanmoins battre les
prévisions et atteindre 2,1 pour cent de
croissance en investissant davantage
dans les infrastructures
sauf que le plan libéral prévoit aussi
une rationalisation des activités de
l'état ce qui pourrait avoir un impact
négatif sur la croissance économique